rivés sur leur écran manette ou clavier
en main près de 5000 jeunes se sont
donné rendez vous pour ce week-end de
trois jours à tour dans les entrailles
du vin si les jeux vidéo se décline sous
toutes leurs formes
et à ce niveau là c'est du sport alors
on parle de sport parce que il ya
beaucoup de similitudes beaucoup de
points communs la façon d'un pca
dedication le fait d'être passionné et
de se dédier entièrement à quelque chose
le fair play le jeu en équipe
les entraînements c'est surtout ça en
fait quand il s'entraîne six à huit
heures par jour
on peut plus parler de jeu c'est pas du
jeu vidéo pour se détendre c'est
vraiment du jeu vidéo de façon fait de
façon professionnelle
donc c'est pour ça qu'on parle de sport
électronique certaines compétitions de
jeux vidéo peuvent rapporter jusqu'à
25000 dollars grâce à l'argent des
éditeurs de jeux vidéo et des sponsors
pour que cette folie du jeu vidéo soit
possible avec des milliers de connexions
internet simultanée 20 webtv des
milliers de pc branché en ligne les
organisateurs ont dû installer une
connexion hors du commun de 10 gigabits
il faut qu'on essaye d'assurer et de
garantir aux joueurs qui jouent en
réseau à sur internet une réactivité
entre le mot il va appuyer sur une
touche de son clavier et le bonhomme qui
va réagir à l'écran où le personnage qui
veut réagir mais qui soit de l'ordre de
1 à 2 millisecondes ça qu'il faut
véritablement assurer une qualité de
connexion simultanée avec le monde
entier qu'ils soient hallucinante
cet événement autour du jeu vidéo nous
vient de suède et semble bien s'adapter
en touraine ce qu'ils appellent la terre
du milieu